everybody's gamescom 2014 John and Andy
here and between you and us we have
somehow managed to sneak into the
microsoft booth where we found some
forza horizon 2 and there's this thing
in the game called skill points which
you'll see in a moment how it works and
Andy what do you think about having a
contest one lap one man we'll see who
can get the most skill points we're not
talking about time here talking about
skill points so what exactly is a skill
point cuz I'm pretty good at like
driving straight ok let's go point for
that no no no no you're gonna drive
what's what's style really good at not
hitting the other players ok if you can
do not hit the other players with style
then you're good ok yeah we're gonna try
doing that I'll go ahead and go all deal
first yellows I'll start I'll go fer get
ready Andy I
alright so I'm going to start I'm going
to get as close as I can to these guys
do you think I got skill points for
those jets flying above us cuz that was
very skillful thing I like to think I
inspired them to fly over us with such
grace right here we got I'm going for
drip oh no oh here we are that uh some
winemakers gonna have a four season
thanks to me let's go cheap I like a bag
great wreckage it was pretty good record
wasn't now I'm gonna do something you
think if I smash into these emails oh oh
oh that definitely lost some momentum on
that one I'm gonna tell this guy gets in
front yeah wooo air awesome
I'm gonna drift on this hill whoa oh you
think I get point big fish failing
because I did a little bit of that just
call you Sean skills we get nothing but
skill points come on Mads actually
that's my gamertag
feeling pretty good right oh no no scale
points for hanging that Fiat and a
head-on collision maybe in the recently
lost my combo there Andy how you feeling
today because I actually guys had no
chance you think you stand no chance
I've been pretty I'm being on the wheel
it's all just it's all you're like a
surgeon yet are you
you think you think I get skill points
for running that GTR into the
Mediterranean because I might have to
try it
give x2 yeah I feel like I should get at
least an X 2
hurry on it's about to get rainy want
you to show you how skillfully I can
hold on to remove or reward for most
skill points is just higher insurance
rates didn't think that's directly how
it works
Oh shatter I think I lost it once that
guy t-boned me because it knows it's the
land it's likely a trick yeah you get
the combo for as long as in doing it and
if you don't do it it'll come out of the
giro thinks it definitely is good help
Oh greedy I got a little bit greedy
there we go alright 75 percent of the
way through this still plenty of time to
be skillful and II don't write me off
yet sounds back out
oh oh ooh I got you sir here we go Union
we're gonna escape Oh God
not today wrong juice
they catch you on that scale I would
never again there we go Oh get milk
don't get greedy hit that wall there
miss is it so going is receptive I'll
watch this record
okay it's getting her street ok so this
chain that's a pretty long time yeah and
there we go oh I got 12th place that's
not what matters though seems like he'll
lose time time his time doesn't matter
i'm looking at skill boy see what i got
twelve thousand nine hundred and forty
pretty good my turn now all right it's
your turn obviously I was in the
Lamborghini last time what do you think
I'm smarter or Chevy I'll try the onion
you look like a you look like a
vanquished kind of guy I've always said
to myself that anybody name is
Vanquisher that's true which ad let's go
yeah absolutely nothing to do with the
car model your parents just thought that
you would kill a lot of people when you
grew up happily they've been very
disappointed it's in my eyes sit here
even as a new so I noticed on yours okay
the skilled chain thing kind of stays up
for a long time and if you tamper get
any I i was at variance with the start
you lose a lot of that skill I'm pretty
sure you're only skill chain got cash in
it like
that's fine that's fine i live i like to
live my life with a lot at stake yeah so
I always try to dance along the razor's
edge until the very end oh I can feel
the dirt in the controller you know I'm
saying yeah horse feedback that was me
knees down go 100 at time yeah wait
let's paint what you're feeling baby did
see what you're feeling are called
impulse triggers oh oh that was a pretty
skillful I was really wasted the way you
gave that tree little love tap kiss I'd
say that was poison hi Annapolis ok
great air kangaroo now ok now what are
you doing no that was weird that was I
got nervous cuz i try to bank it in
Roman you don't look at me alright hit
me look how skilled a I'm like I'll give
you can give you one piece of driving
advice its to look at the television
screen that is a virtual approximation
of the road I can just feel it ok that's
how I'm think I don't think you get
extra points for not looking at the
screen all right straight a little cocky
great pass yeah that's good right bank
it go thank ya there you go all right
all right you got that one in the bank I
think the connector know you're a a is
the handbrake on you want to drift with
that yeah I'm saving my drapes the more
okay I don't
save your [ __ ] you don't want to use all
your drifts too early when you can
collect a lot of points no you want to
sing when it's from being racing yeah
I
no oh ok I didn't even get it Andy
you're you're losing focus here I want
you to get into the spirit of the Aston
Martin I'm just bank with bank or some
dress yeah no no no nope not quite not
quite I like your style I like your
dedication to drifting but I think he
might have drifted a little bit too
early on that one yeah you've got this
that's raining now conditions are a
little okay all right okay that was
skillful technical trips cameras off the
room technically you still have to turn
that's one thing to keep in mind
Indian beginning to worry about you
really came out of nowhere he did in
fairness that came out all right there
you go thank the drift pink toes 104
yeah see there you go slow and steady if
you invest young kids soon nope
I'm going to the story I'm do the
shortcut how do i give me go give you
some amount remember you pick the tail
out and then oh and it was gonna say
take the wrong out and then don't hit
the wrong but you went the other way
that's fine okay all right there you go
bake it Thank fake it next bank didn't
work no my hitting this ya hit that bus
stop yeah
all right it's good I feel like I
kidding you Oh hahaha area it's okay um
banco get style point thank thank some
of the landscaper is gonna be very
anything but you got some style points
all right there it is the moment of
truth what was it Andy what was it I
don't know we'll see how much i was able
to invest early no or thousand no 670
well Andy I didn't even get half I think
today we learned who the more skillful
driver is here's a spoiler it's me